okay another question what's your
long-term game plan jason continue angel
investing until you drop move on up
later and larger series so
uh great question the syndicate has
grown to nine thousand members the
syndicate.com the largest angel
syndicate in the world there's three
syndicates there the all-in syndicate
the sas syndicate and uh where we also
have the um jason syndicate the original
syndicate so
we have been investing in round after
round after round
so what that means is we will maintain
our position sometimes go down a little
bit or sometimes increase it and we've
been participating in rounds that are
you know hundreds of millions of dollars
i don't want to be a late stage investor
i find that very boring you know to put
the last 100 million dollars into a
company i kind of like the more
you know seed space you know the
formation all the way up to you know
hitting a unicorn status uh i would i
would have liked uh if i'm being honest
to have been on the board of uber com
and robin hood when they went public but
i own such small amounts of those
companies that maybe i wouldn't have
been a board member but that would be a
bucket list for me
is to have one of these other companies
that we do have a board seat on to go
public and be on the board when they do
and and to learn that i've never done
that so
um i am trying to get um you know the
investment team to find deals to share
them with the syndicate and have the
syndicate make the decision if they want
to invest with their own dollars without
me saying this is explicitly a jason
deal there'll be jason syndicate which
does jason's deals but i want the sas
syndicate the new one we started to have
the syndicate members vote on it so
there's a very new concept you know i
think we have over 500 people join that
syndicate already and so if the 500 sas
investors say this is a good company
we want you to manage the investment for
us
do the diligence get the board seat
get the information rights review the
legal then investments could be
happening in sas companies without me
being involved in because how do you
scale you know one person right and
that's uh to other questions folks have
had is how do you scale this jason
that's the way we're going to scale it
is the syndicate members will decide
which ones to invest in so great
question and my energy level is high
right now my motivation level's high
uh so i think i got another 10 years of
doing this i really do want to write the
book and i want to write more i'm
envisioning a life where i
do the podcast i write and i do the
select investments that i like and i
keep building this syndicate up so
that's that's three me and then of
course i'm still running inside.com uh
and that's going wonderfully and i'm
learning a lot there too so i really
have four things on my plate but you
know i like to work
and what am i gonna do retire and like
it's really boring like you know when i
mean if i retire the only thing i could
see myself retiring to do would be if i
retired to just be a full-time writer i
actually could see that and i did see it
when i was you know at the beach in
italy writing for a solid week i was
like could get used to this
it was a little isolating but it was
also inspiring to be able to
refine the sentences and work on the
pros so
thank you for your interest